jetzt geht es direkt weiter mit meiner
kollegin jeanette klag die steht seit
dem frühen morgen bei den grünen
jeanette was steht im vordergrund ein
bisschen wundenlecken immer noch über
das was man nicht erreicht hat oder ist
der starre blick jetzt schon dahin was
man jetzt in zukunft erreichen will
ganz klar der blick bei den grünen der
geht nach vorne man hat sich gestern
nicht allzu viel zeit genommen um zu
sagen ja man hat eigene fehler gemacht
das hat annalena baerbock die grünen
kanzlerkandidaten eingeräumt schon kurz
nach der ersten hochrechnung dass auch
sie eigene fehler gemacht hat während
des wahlkampfes darüber ist ja viel
gesprochen und berichtet worden aber
dann hat man sich bei den grünen
tatsächlich sehr sehr schnell sortiert
und bereits gestern abend saß ein grüne
spitzen kreis zusammen um robert habeck
und annalena baerbock auf winfried
kretschmann war beispielsweise dabei
oder auch der europaabgeordnete sven
giegold bis tief in die nacht bis
ungefähr halb zwei hat man da zusammen
gesessen und natürlich ging es da schon
darum wie stellt man sich auf für
mögliche vorgespräche für mögliche
sondierung der die ersten signale die
gab es ja gestern nicht nur olaf scholz
und armin laschet erheben ja beide den
anspruch eine regierung bilden zu wollen
und haben schon mal angekündigt dass die
gespräche führen wollen mit den grünen
und mit der fdp sondern es gab gestern
abend ja auch bereits signale für einen
schulterschluss zwischen den liberalen
zwischen der fdp und den grünen dass man
gesagt hat es wäre doch eigentlich gerne
ganz gute idee wenn sich erstmal diese
beiden zusammensetzen würden und
ausmachen würden welche gemeinsamkeiten
und welche knackpunkte es gibt es ist
natürlich eine strategisch sehr gute
lage also grüne und fdp die
möglicherweise hier zum königsmacher zum
kanzler macher werden können ja und
darauf guckt man hier hinter mir eine
heinrich-böll-stiftung der sitzt der
grüne vorstand zusammen und beschäftigt
sich weiter genau mit diesen fragen und
zu möglichen gesprächen ist auch robert
habeck gefragt worden wer hier vor
ungefähr zehn minuten die
heinrich-böll-stiftung betreten hat und
das wollen wir ihnen zeigen
217 die sondierungsgespräche sind unter
anderem schief gegangen weil man alles
permanent ausgeplaudert hat ich glaube
ist für alle die leute die jetzt die
aufgaben aufgabe haben deutschland eine
regierung zu bauen ein guter hinweis
nicht alles was sie wissen auf der zunge
und zu markte zu tragen
genau das meinte ich es gibt
gremiensitzung und es gibt dann
irgendwann auf den moment wo wir sie und
alle anderen leute die interessiert sind
informieren aber
die indiskretion ist der tod von jeder
form in einer komplizierten gemengelage
zu einer zu einer neuen politik zu
kommen und deswegen werde ich mich immer
nur an die diskussion halten und dann
mich zu wort melden beziehungsweise wir
uns zu wort melden wenn ihr was zu sagen
haben
präferenzen es gibt ein
wahlergebnis das ja die spd vor der
union sieht das ist ein
das hat der souverän so gemacht und das
muss man auch ernst nehmen damit gibt es
einen brief finde ich war erwartbar
erstmals die sondierung einlädt
andererseits gibt es eben auch beispiele
dass jung gebildet wurden wohl nicht die
stärkste kraft den ministerpräsidenten
oder den kanzler weiß ich gar nicht aber
ministerpräsidenten gestellt hat
baden-württemberg ist ein beispiel
insofern gibt es eine logik aus dem
wahlergebnis daraus aber keine finale
lösung in der ganzen geschichte sondern
wir werden vielleicht beraten wie wir
das jetzt formal machen und ich habe es
gestern abend schon gesagt da ja
vergleichsweise sicher ist dass fdp und
grüne in der nächsten regierung dabei
sein werden und allgemein bekannt ist
dass fdp und grüne sich bei fragen wie
finanzsteuer sozialpolitik rolle des
staates rolle des marktes nicht
unbedingt immer einig waren es ist eine
gute idee dass diejenigen die erst mal
am weitesten weg sind auf der
politischen skala mal gucken ob sie
miteinander was hinkriegen und eine
brücke bauen können und punkte finden
die vielleicht auch nur in dieser
konstellation gelingen können und das
wäre mein tipp so in diese sondierungs
gespräche einzusteigen und mal gucken
wie wir das jetzt auf die auf die auf
die reihe kriegen lassen
man muss nicht so lange darüber
nachdenken um zu sehen dass in denen
allen bereichen
von bürgerrechten von innen politik von
liberalität im
ursprünglichen sinne des wortes also
nicht wirtschaftlicher liberalität
sondern rechtlicher liberalität eine
große schnittmenge besteht und das sind
ja im wahlkampf zwar nicht so stark
diskutierte fragen aber in der
gesellschaft hoch virulente fragen
fragen von gleichstellung
gleichberechtigung von integration von
zuwanderung von einwanderung von
facharbeitern da gibt es natürlich eine
große nähe erst einmal zwischen fdp und
grünen
weitere fragen sind denkbar aber so
meine ich das nicht man muss uns sagen
anfangen über gast gemeinsam
nachzudenken und nicht erst mal eine
lange liste auf zulauf zu schreiben was
findet man alles beruf aneinander weil
es nicht wenn man schon mal eine
beziehung eingehen wollte und erst mal
gefragt hat so jetzt erstmal was hinzu
du von mir und dann sagt mir du
schneidest du selbst die milchtüte mehr
verkehrt im kühlschrank und zu spät
kommst du auch immer plus zehn weitere
dinge und dann sagt man so und die
wollen wir uns jetzt sozusagen eine
wohnung gemeinsam teilen das geht
natürlich gerade schief also muss man es
genau andersrum machen
keine aufstellung sondern eine arbeits
gemeinsamkeit wie es sich gehört für
bundesvorsitzende und die gemeinsam
gewählt und gemeinsam die parteileitung
und
robert habeck kurz bevor er zur sitzung
des bundesvorstandes der grünen in die
heinrich böll stiftung
hineingegangen ist und natürlich ist er
gefragt worden was die knackpunkte und
dass die schnittmengen gerade zwischen
fdp und grünen sind denn es deutet sehr
viel darauf hin dass fdp und grüne sich
zumindest zu vorgesprächen schon in den
nächsten tagen
verabreden werden das ist auch eine
konsequenz aus den erfahrungen der
jamaica verhandlungen vor vier jahren da
war man sich ja gerade zwischen den
liberalen und den grünen doch sehr
entfernt vor allem nicht nur was das
inhaltliche angelangt sondern gerade was
das gemeinsame verständnis anbelangt was
die persönlichen kontakte betrifft da
ist in den letzten jahren einiges
passiert es gibt diverse informelle
gesprächskreise beispielsweise zwischen
den innenpolitikern von fdp und von den
grünen rund um konstantin von notz den
fraktionsvize der grünen und konstantin
coole von der fdp an lebens stern kreist
nach der bar benannt wo man sich
getroffen hat zumindest in der vor
geraumer zeit auch andere kreise haben
sich gebildet und noch mal daran sei
erinnert die zusammenarbeit zwischen fdp
und den grünen im bundestag in den
letzten vier jahren in der opposition
die war ja durchaus auch gegeben
beispielsweise in den
untersuchungsausschüssen zur pkw maut
und zum wirecard skandal aber auch was
eine wahlrechtsreform anbelangt da hat
man eng zusammen gearbeitet also man
kennt sich wesentlich besser als vor
vier jahren und das wird bei diesen
gesprächen natürlich eine rolle spielen
und wenn wir alexander dobrindt aus
münchen gehört haben daher schon mal
gesagt hat das geht natürlich nicht dass
fdp und grüne schon mal vorher
vereinbarung treffen bevor sie sich
überhaupt unmöglich mit union und spd
treffen aber natürlich können sich die
beiden zusammen setzen die richtigen
gespräche natürlich das werden dann drei
oder wenn es um jamaika geht muss man
die csu ja noch dazu nehmen vierer
gespräche seien also werden mal hören ob
wir nach der vorstandssitzung hier
einiges noch bei den grünen erfahren
jetzt geht's erst mal zurück zu julia
krim in den reichstag